This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. The largest body of water in California was formed by mistake. In 1905, the California Development Company accidentally flooded a huge salty depression in the Sonoran Desert known as the Salt and Sink, creating an enormous salty lake called the Salt and Sea. And here we are at the edge of the Salt and Sea. It's incredible, you almost can't see across and we're just at the tip, it's pretty narrow here. Reporter Emmett Fitzgerald recently visited the Salt and Sea on a hot summer day in the desert. Yeah, it's just a mile to 107 right now.
这里是“99%隐形”节目。我是罗曼·马尔斯。加利福尼亚州最大的水体其实是因一次失误而形成的。1905年，加利福尼亚开发公司不小心淹没了一个位于索诺兰沙漠的巨大咸水洼地，该洼地被称为“萨尔顿洼地”，从而形成了一个巨大的咸水湖——萨尔顿海。现在我们来到了萨尔顿海的边缘。这太不可思议了，你几乎望不到对岸，而我们现在还只是在它的边缘，这里相当狭窄。记者埃米特·菲茨杰拉德最近在沙漠炎热的一个夏日走访了萨尔顿海。是的，从这里到107号公路只有一英里了。
The water is twice as salty as the Pacific Ocean. The only fish that can live there are tilapia, and even they struggle sometimes. It's just a lion of dead fish, dead tilapia. And then, oh my gosh, flies everywhere. The ground beneath the southern end of the sea is volcanic and boiling water bubbles to the surface in muddy pools. It feels post-apocalyptic and prehistoric all at the same time, but it's also weirdly beautiful. And the sea isn't dead, the water is teeming with microbial life and the beaches are covered
这里的湖水盐度是太平洋的两倍。唯一能在那里生存的鱼类是罗非鱼，甚至连它们有时也难以存活。到处都是死鱼，死去的罗非鱼排成一条线。然后，天哪，到处都是苍蝇。萨尔顿海南端的地表是火山地质，沸腾的水从泥潭中冒出气泡。这种感觉既有末日后的荒凉，又带有史前洪荒的色彩，但它也有一种诡异的美感。而且这座海并非死水一族，水里充满了微生物，海滩上布满了
with sandpipers, egrids, and pelicans. This sea, in this gurgling, sometimes stinky, accident of a sea, is actually in danger of drying up and disappearing. And you may be thinking, good riddance, it doesn't sound all that nice, and you wouldn't be alone. Over the years, it's been hard to get people to care about saving the salt and sea, in part because it doesn't seem natural enough. In general, we tend to think about places and objects
鹬鸟、白鹭和鹈鹕。这片海，这片发出咕噜声、有时甚至散发着恶臭的、由失误造成的湖泊，实际上正面临着干涸和消失的危险。你可能会想，谢天谢地，这听起来一点也不好，你并不是唯一这么想的人。多年来，人们很难对拯救萨尔顿海产生兴趣，部分原因是因为它看起来不够天然。总的来说，我们倾向于将地方和物体
as either natural or unnatural. Forest, natural. City, unnatural. But that black and white distinction is sometimes greater than it seems. Today, Paragon Falcons are nesting on skyscrapers. Coral reefs are growing on oil dericks, and some seemingly wild ecosystems are carefully managed by humans. The truth is, a lot of places on earth are the messy result of a combination of natural
划分为天然的或非天然的。森林，天然的。城市，非天然的。但这种非黑即白的区别有时比看上去要模糊得多。如今，游隼在摩天大楼上筑巢。珊瑚礁在石油钻井平台上生长，一些看似野生的生态系统其实受到人类的精心管理。事实是，地球上的许多地方都是自然事件和非自然事件交织在一起的杂乱产物。
and unnatural events. No where is messier than the salt and sea. And it raises the question, should we protect an ecosystem that's not purely natural? The salt and sink has not always been full of water, but it hasn't always been empty either. Over centuries, the meandering Colorado River would periodically flow into the sink and fill it with water, and then over time, the water would dry up. This cycle repeated itself every four or five hundred years or so. But when white settlers showed up in the desert in the late 1800s, there was no sea there
没有哪个地方比萨尔顿海更混乱了。这就引发了一个问题：我们是否应该保护一个并非纯天然的生态系统？萨尔顿洼地并非一直都充满了水，但它也并非一直空无一物。几个世纪以来，蜿蜒的科罗拉多河会周期性地流入这个洼地并将其注满水，随着时间的推移，水分又会蒸发干涸。这个循环每四五百年重复一次。但当19世纪末白人定居者来到这片沙漠时，这里根本没有海，
at all, just a parched basin, a trough, 270 feet below sea level at its deepest, and filled with natural salt deposits, which companies harvested to sell in cities like San Francisco. But frontier developers soon realized that if you brought in water, you could grow crops 12 months a year under the desert sun. So they said about rebranding this place as an agricultural paradise. And they started by getting rid of the name, Salt and Sink. Well, that's not a very appealing name if you're trying to sell lots. So they thought of imperial value, it sounded great.
只有一个干涸的盆地，一个最低点低于海平面270英尺的槽谷，里面充满了天然盐沉积物，公司开采这些盐并在旧金山等城市销售。但边境开发商很快意识到，如果你把水引进来，你就可以在沙漠的烈日下一年12个月种植农作物。于是他们着手将这个地方重新包装成一个农业天堂。他们首先去掉了“萨尔顿洼地”这个名字。嗯，如果你想卖地，这个名字可不太吸引人。于是他们想到了“帝王谷”，听起来棒极了。
That's Pat Lafflin. She's a local historian who's lived in the area for the last 60 years. They established a water company which would bring water by canal from the Colorado River. They said if you start a farm here, we'll bring you the water. This water came into Imperial Valley and watered the acreage. And these real estate developers sold a lot of lots in Europe to people who wanted to come to America and get a new start. And they had a wonderful agricultural industry going down there.
那是帕特·拉夫林。她是一名当地历史学家，在当地生活了过去60年。“他们成立了一家水务公司，通过运河从科罗拉多河引水。他们说，如果你在这里开办农场，我们就给你引水。这些水流入帝王谷并灌溉了这里的土地。这些房地产开发商在欧洲卖出了很多土地，卖给那些想来美国重新开始的人。他们在那里建立了一个非常棒的农业产业。”
For a few years anyway, in 1905 the water company cut a new canal and before they had time to reinforce it. They had a very late flood up river in the Colorado, and the water just came through and washed out that cut and flooded the valley. Water broke through the wall of the canal and poured into the salt and sink, destroying farms and homes.
至少维持了几年。1905年，水务公司开凿了一条新运河，还没来得及加固，上游的科罗拉多河就发生了罕见的晚汛，河水直接冲过来，冲毁了那个缺口，淹没了整个山谷。水冲破了运河的堤岸，倾泻进萨尔顿洼地，摧毁了农田和家园。
It was a disaster. And it just kept pouring in. The federal government could not be bothered to help, so the task of stopping the flow of water fell mostly to the Southern Pacific Railway, which had lost train tracks in the flood, and would lose more if they did nothing. It was an amazing task.
这是一场灾难。而且水还在不断涌入。联邦政府懒得提供帮助，因此堵住水流的任务主要落在了南太平洋铁路公司身上，该公司在洪水中损失了铁轨，如果什么都不做，还会损失更多。这是一项惊人的任务。
They built railroad tracks out to the break in the dike, and then they just took flat car loads of cement and old cars or any junk that they could throw in because there was just no solid bottom there to the river. It was all sandy. They did this for an entire year until they finally managed to fill in the breach and get the river back into its channel. But by that point the water had filled up the salt and sink, creating a massive lake
他们把铁轨铺到堤坝的缺口处，然后用平板车运来水泥、旧汽车或任何他们能扔进去的垃圾，因为河底根本没有坚实的基底，全都是沙子。他们这样干了一整年，直到最后终于设法填补了缺口，让河水回到了河道。但到了那个时候，水已经注满了萨尔顿洼地，在沙漠中心形成了一个巨大的湖泊。
in the middle of the desert. The salt and sea. And most people assumed it would just dry up like a puddle on a hot day. Which is what it usually did whenever the Colorado flowed into the salt and sink. But the sea had a new water source this time, agriculture. As irrigation flowed off the fields in the Imperial Valley, it ran downhill into the sink and sustained the salt and sea. And for much of the 20th century, the runoff coming into the sea was about the same as
——萨尔顿海。大多数人原以为它会像炎热天气里的水坑一样很快干涸，科罗拉多河流入萨尔顿洼地时通常就是这样的。但这一次，这片海有了新的水源——农业。随着灌溉水从帝王谷的农田流出，它们顺着山坡流入洼地，维持着萨尔顿海的存在。在20世纪的大部分时间里，流入海里的径流量大约等于蒸发掉的水量，
the amount of water being lost to evaporation, creating a strange balance that made the sea appear stable. And back then, the sea was pretty different than it is now. It looked like a peaceful oasis and an otherwise hostile desert, like somewhere you might want to go on vacation. In the 1950s, a new round of developers saw a chance to turn the sea into a playground for Los Angeles Weekenders. They called it the California Riviera.
从而形成了一种奇妙的平衡，使海面看起来很稳定。当年的萨尔顿海和现在有着很大的不同。它看起来就像是充满敌意的沙漠中的一片宁静绿洲，就像你想去度假的地方。在20世纪50年代，新一轮的开发商看到了将这片海变成洛杉矶周末度假者游乐场的机会。他们称之为“加利福尼亚里维埃拉”。
Here is truly a miracle in the desert, a whole new outlet for the crowded millions in big cities, a palm springs with water. Here is where you can find the good life in the sun. Today, the Salton River... In oil tycoon, named Penn Phillips, built a plan community on the west side of the lake called Sultan City. He put in a yacht club over there and laid out lots and sold lots and brought busloads of people down to see the sea and purchase lots. That's Pat Lafflin again. She used to take her family to the Sultan Sea on weekends. It was really a wonderful place to go for recreation when I first came in
“这里真的是沙漠中的奇迹，为大城市里拥挤的数百万人开辟了一个全新的去处，一个带水的棕榈泉。在这里，你可以在阳光下找到美好的生活。今天，萨尔顿河……”一位名叫彭·菲利普斯的石油大亨在湖的西侧规划了一个名为萨尔顿城的社区。他在那里建了一个游艇俱乐部，划分了地块，卖了地，还用大巴车载着人们来看海并买地。
1950. And I have memories of many hamburger fries on the beach and swimming, but the water was great and there was water skiing and they had a lot of boat races across the sea and back. And then there were the fish. The California Department of Fish and Game decided to stock the sea with fish in order to encourage more tourism. Scientists at UCLA worked to design the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish and the C-Fish the Gulf of Baja California and they brought in the brine fish and then whatever the brine fish came and then the next thing up the chain. The water was salty but not too salty, and so they tried a mix of fresh water and salt water species.
说话的又是帕特·拉夫林。她过去常常在周末带家人去萨尔顿海。“当我1950年刚来的时候，那里确实是一个休闲的好地方。我记忆中有在海滩上吃汉堡、游泳的美好时光，水很好，还可以滑水，那里举行了很多横渡萨尔顿海及往返的船只比赛。”然后就是鱼类。加州鱼类和野生动物局决定在海里放养鱼类，以鼓励更多旅游业的发展。加州大学洛杉矶分校的科学家们致力于设计海水鱼，他们从加利福尼亚湾（即加利福尼亚湾）引进了咸水鱼，然后是咸水鱼带来的生物，接着是食物链上的下一环。水是咸的，但不是太咸，所以他们尝试了淡水和咸水物种的组合。
And a lot of this work was done by biologists, but some of it was just renegade fishermen. They tried all kinds of fish, they tried harbor seals, and they survived, I guess, for a while. After a while, they didn't see any of many more. That's Steve Horvitz, a retired ranger with the California State Parks. Spent about 10 years down at the Salt and Sea, living in a desert. Steve says that a few fish, like tilapia, sargo, and corvina, thrived. And by the 1960s, the Salt and Sea was one of the most popular fishing destinations
许多这类工作是由生物学家完成的，但其中一些只是由叛逆的渔民完成的。他们尝试了各种各样的鱼，他们尝试过海豹，我想它们存活了一段时间。过了一段时间，人们就再也没看到它们了。说话的是史蒂夫·霍维茨，加州州立公园的一名退休护林员。在萨尔顿海生活了大约10年，生活在沙漠中。史蒂夫说，少数几种鱼类，如罗非鱼、萨尔戈鱼和科维纳鱼，在这里繁衍生息。到20世纪60年代，萨尔顿海已经成为全国最受欢迎的垂钓胜地之一。
in the country. The marinas were full of boaters. The marinas were full of life, and the bars were full, and it was packed. They were a run of cars coming from the LA area down to the Salt and Sea every weekend. Stars like the Beach Boys and Frank Sinatra touled around the lake in motorboats. And they gave concerts and programs on the
码头上挤满了乘船游玩的人。码头上充满了生机，酒吧里人满为患，挤得水泄不通。每个周末都有成串的汽车从洛杉矶地区开往萨尔顿海。海滩男孩乐队和弗兰克·辛纳屈等明星驾驶着摩托艇在湖上游弋。他们还在萨尔顿海的岸边举办了音乐会和节目。
shore of the Salt and Sea. Was a place to go. There was a time when more people went to the Salt and Sea than went to Yosemite. time and more people went to the Salt and Sea then went to Yosemite. But the good life in the sun didn't last all that long. In the 70s and 80s, floods knocked out a lot of the infrastructure along the shoreline. And most of the owners of the marinas and the yacht clubs decided not to rebuild. By then people began thinking that maybe there were more issues and then they were aware with the Salt and sea. And they were right. One of the biggest issues was salinity.
这里曾是一个必去的地方。曾几何时，去萨尔顿海的人比去约塞米蒂国家公园的人还要多。但阳光下的美好生活并没有持续多久。在70年代和80年代，洪水摧毁了海岸线上的许多基础设施。大多数码头和游艇俱乐部的所有者决定不再重建。到那时，人们开始觉得，除了萨尔顿海表面上的风光，可能还有更多的问题。他们是对的。最大的问题之一就是盐度。
The water entering the salt and sea picks up salts from the soil. And those salts have nowhere to go. Salt and sea is a closed body of water. The only way water leaves is it evaporates and as water evaporates the material the solids stay. And so the salt concentration continues to increase and increase and increase. Every year the sea gets saltier and saltier, which is a natural process for lakes with no outlet. But tourists didn't like super salty water, smelly fish dios and massive algae blooms. By the 1990s most of the marinas and hotels had closed their doors, and a lot of people had left town.
流入萨尔顿海的水从土壤中带走了盐分。而这些盐分无处可去。萨尔顿海是一个封闭的水体。水离开的唯一方式是蒸发，随着水蒸发，物质即固体留了下来。因此，盐分浓度不断增加、增加、再增加。湖水每年变得越来越咸，这对于没有出海口的湖泊来说是一个自然过程。但游客并不喜欢超高盐度的水、发臭的死鱼和大规模的藻类华。到了20世纪90年代，大部分码头和酒店都关门大吉，许多人也离开了小镇。
A rugged contingent stuck it out in small sea-side towns, but the dream of the California Riviera was over. And then in the mid-90s, the sea began to dry up. Remember, pretty much the only water going into the sea was from agricultural runoff. But over the years, farms had become more efficient with water. They installed drip irrigation systems that reduced the runoff draining into the sea. Then in 2003, as part of a complicated water deal, the water district in Imperial Valley sold off the rights to a lot of their water, mostly to San Diego. Some farmers in the area had to stop watering their fields which meant less water draining
一小群坚韧的人在海滨小镇坚持了下来，但加州里维埃拉的梦想已经破灭。然后，在90年代中期，这片海开始干涸。记住，流入海里的几乎唯一水源是农业径流。但多年来，农场在用水方面变得更加高效。他们安装了滴灌系统，减少了排入海里的径流。随后在2003年，作为一项复杂的水权交易的一部分，帝王谷的水务区卖掉了他们的大部分水权，主要卖给了圣地亚哥。当地的一些农民不得不停止灌溉农田，这意味着排入萨尔顿海的水变少了。
into the salt and sea. Steve Horvitz and many other local people fought hard against the water transfer, which they say was done without a proper environmental review. They lobbied politicians in Sacramento and Washington demanding a plan for saving the salt and sea. But few lawmakers wanted to prioritize a fading tourist destination. In the 90s, celebrity congressman Sonny Bono had been a champion for the sea,
史蒂夫·霍维茨和许多当地人强烈反对这次调水，他们称这次调水是在没有进行适当的环境评估的情况下进行的。他们向萨克拉门托和华盛顿的政客游说，要求制定拯救萨尔顿海的计划。但很少有议员愿意优先考虑一个日渐衰落的旅游目的地。在90年代，名人国会议员桑尼·博诺曾是这片海的坚定捍卫者，
but he died in a ski accident in 1998. Steve Horvitz says that he even had trouble getting help from environmental groups. Some environmentalists that I knew they would discount the solaceous, just a wasted body of water, it's just a man-made lake, and so why are you so worried about it?
但他于1998年在一次滑雪事故中丧生。史蒂夫·霍维茨说，他甚至很难从环保组织那里得到帮助。“我认识的一些环保主义者会贬低萨尔顿海，说它只是一具浪费的水体，它只是一个人造湖，所以你为什么这么担心它？”
And I was amazed by that. You know, many people talk to us about why restored the salt and sea. It was an accident. That's Bruce Wilcox. I'm the assistant secretary for natural resources agency in charge of salt and sea policy. And Bruce takes issue with people who call it an accidental sea. This latest version of the salt and sea was an accident, but there's lots of geologic history that shows that the Imperial Valley was flooded periodically by the Colorado River. Either way, wildlife doesn't really care whether or not the lake is an accident.
这让我感到震惊。你知道，许多人跟我们谈论为什么要恢复萨尔顿海。它是一场意外。这是布鲁斯·威尔考克斯的话。我是自然资源局负责萨尔顿海政策的助理秘书。布鲁斯对那些称其为意外之海的人持不同意见。最新版本的萨尔顿海确实是一场意外，但有大量的地质历史表明，帝王谷曾周期性地被科罗拉多河淹没。不管怎样，野生动物并不真正在乎这个湖是否是一场意外。
Just look at all the birds. Ducks, geese, stilts, and douchers, hair and brown pelicans, and white pelicans, a large population of white pelicans. There are about 425 different species that have been catalardt or identified it to salt and sea. Aside from the Texas Gulf, the salt and sea has more bird species than any other place in the US.
看看所有的鸟类就知道了。鸭子、大雁、长脚鹬、潜水鸟、苍鹭、褐鹈鹕和白鹈鹕，庞大的白鹈鹕种群。在萨尔顿海已经记录或识别出大约425种不同的鸟类。除了得克萨斯湾，萨尔顿海拥有的鸟类物种比美国其他任何地方都要多。
Many of those birds migrate up and down North America and the birds would stop at marshes in Southern California to refuel. But those marshes aren't there anymore. Most of the wetlands in Southern California are actuallyuel. But those marshes aren't there anymore. Most of the wetlands in Southern California are actually probably in all of California. I've disappeared because of development of one kind or another.
其中许多鸟类在北美南北迁徙，它们会停留在南加州的沼泽地补充体力。但那些沼泽已经不在了。南加州的大部分湿地实际上……可能整个加州的大部分湿地，都因为某种形式的开发而消失了。
The sun sees one of the last stops they have. So if we lose that link, if it dries up, we'll crash a lot of bird populations. And there's another reason not to let the sea evaporate. Probably the most compelling reason is human health. As the sea recedes, it exposes dry lake bed, called playa, and it's made up of tiny dust particles that can get into your lungs and cause respiratory diseases, like asthma. To make matters worse, heavy metals and other toxins from all that agricultural runoff
萨尔顿海是它们最后的落脚点之一。因此，如果我们失去这个纽带，如果它干涸了，我们将导致许多鸟类种群崩溃。不让海水蒸发的另一个原因。可能最令人信服的原因是人类健康。随着海面退缩，露出了干涸的湖床（被称为普拉亚），它由微小的灰尘颗粒组成，这些颗粒会进入你的肺部并导致哮喘等呼吸道疾病。更糟糕的是，来自所有这些农业径流的重金属和其他毒素
have settled at the bottom of the lake. So there's a tremendous health risk. And not just for people living near the sea. Toxic dust could get blown as far away as Phoenix, Arizona. The Pacific Institute of Water Think Tank in Oakland wrote a report in 2014 saying that the cost of doing nothing at the Salt and Sea
已经沉淀在湖底。因此存在巨大的健康风险。而且不仅仅是对居住在海湖附近的人来说。有毒沙尘甚至可能被吹到远至亚利桑那州菲尼克斯的地方。位于奥克兰的水资源智库“太平洋研究所”在2014年发布了一份报告称，对萨尔顿海什么都不做的代价在未来30年内可能高达700亿美元。
could be as high as $70 billion over the next 30 years. As part of that 2003 water transfer, California agreed to send some water to the Salt and Sea for a few years, to keep the salinity in check while they figure out a solution to the dust and the birds. That water will stop flowing after 2017. But there is a little glimmer of hope. This year, California approved $80 million for a new Salt and Sea task force, which Bruce Wilcox heads up, and are using the funds to start designing ways to keep the dust down
作为2003年水权转让协议的一部分，加州同意在几年内向萨尔顿海输送一些水，在他们找到解决沙尘和鸟类问题的方案的同时控制盐度。这些水将在2017年后停止流动。但还是有一丝希望的。今年，加州批准了8000万美元用于一个新的萨尔顿海特别工作组（由布鲁斯·威尔考克斯领导），他们正利用这些资金开始设计各种方法来减少沙尘并吸引鸟类回归，同时大幅减少用水量。
and the birds coming back, all using a lot less water. The plan is basically to build artificial wetlands, with water cycling between ponds of varying salinity levels, each designed to support different bird species, and there'll be walkways and boat launches, so people can enjoy the resource too. But there's no blueprint for this kind of ecosystem architecture. In planning an ecosystem runs counter to a pretty basic ecological principle, that nature knows best. For a lot of environments environments the best approach is to keep humans as far away as possible. But it's too late for that at the salt and sea.
该计划基本上是建立人工湿地，让水在不同盐度等级的池塘之间循环，每个池塘都旨在支持不同的鸟类物种，还将修建人行道和游艇码头，以便人们也能享受这里的资源。但这种生态系统架构没有现成的蓝图。规划生态系统违背了一个相当基础的生态学原则，即“自然知晓最好”。对于许多环境而言，最好的方法是让人类离得越远越好。但对于萨尔顿海来说，现在为时已晚。
Humans have transformed this landscape really the entire Colorado River Basin in such profound ways. We damned up the river and irrigated the desert. We have dried up all the wetlands. We have made all these modifications for better or worse. And now we're in a position where we have to step in and manage. That's Bruce Wilcox again, the Assistant Secretary for Salt and Sea Policy. And I would be lying to you if I didn't say I was a little nervous about that,
人类彻底改造了这个景观，实际上是以如此深远的方式改造了整个科罗拉多河流域。我们筑坝拦河，灌溉沙漠。我们干涸了所有的湿地。无论好坏，我们做出了所有这些改变。现在我们处于不得不介入并进行管理的境地。再次引用布鲁斯·威尔考克斯的话，他是萨尔顿海政策助理秘书。如果我说对此不感到有点紧张，那我就是在撒谎，
because we don't know anywhere near as much as we think. It's just a little bit arrogant to think we screwed it all up and then suddenly we decided we can fix it. I mean, there's a danger in that. But we're in a position where we don't have a choice. Building hundreds of acres of artificial wetlands is going to require a lot of money. Much more than the 80 million they just got. And that means California is going to have to start valuing a landscape that's the furthest thing from pristine.
因为我们对它的了解远没有我们想象的那么多。认为我们把一切都搞砸了，然后突然决定我们能修复它，这未免有点傲慢。我的意思是，这其中存在危险。但我们处于别无选择的境地。建造数百英亩的人工湿地需要大量的资金。远不止他们刚获得的8000万美元。这意味着加州将不得不开始珍视一个远非原始的景观。
It's easy to contrast the saltancy with California's second largest body of water, Lake Tahoe, the beautiful blue mountain lake that northern California, yuppies, and hippies, and yuppies who used to be hippies flock to every weekend. Tahoe is sexy. There's no doubt, but the saltancy at former park ranger Steve Horvitz. to every weekend. Every where you go in California, they're bumper stickers that say keep Tahoe blue. It's almost a badge of environmentalism out here. The salt and sea might not be as beautiful or as natural as Lake Tahoe, but we need it all the same. But if the salt and sea is going to get saved, it'll need to get appreciated first.
人们很容易将萨尔顿海与加州第二大水体——太浩湖进行对比，这是一个美丽的高山蓝湖，北加州的雅皮士、嬉皮士以及曾经是嬉皮士的雅皮士们每个周末都会蜂拥而至。太浩湖充满了性感迷人。毫无疑问，但萨尔顿海……前公园护林员史蒂夫·霍维茨说：“你在加州走到哪里，都会看到印有‘保持太浩湖湛蓝’字样的汽车贴纸。这在这里几乎成了环保主义的徽章。萨尔顿海可能不像太浩湖那样美丽或天然，但我们同样需要它。”但如果萨尔顿海要得救，首先需要得到人们的欣赏。
We're going to need to see some of the bumper stickers. We just got to think of a slogan, and it probably can't be Save the hot sweaty guy in the desert So, um, let's see See you at the salt and see make the salt and see great again Redesign the Riviera the salt and see is for the birds we came we saw the salt and see maintain the mistake Don't add salt in the womb keep God on your your right shoulder and saltin' on your left. Philapia, I hardly know ya. That's the one.
我们需要看到一些那样的汽车贴纸。我们只需要想出一个标语，它大概不能是“拯救沙漠里那个满头大汗的性感男人”。所以，嗯，让我们看看：萨尔顿海见、让萨尔顿海再次伟大、重新设计里维埃拉、萨尔顿海属于鸟类、我们来过我们看过萨尔顿海、保持这个失误、胸怀大志并随时准备向左向右看……罗非鱼，我几乎不认识你。就是这个。
99% invisible was produced this week by Emmett Fitzgerald with Sheree Fusef, Katie Mingle, Kurt Colstead, Sam Greenspan, Avery, Troubleman, and me Roman Mars. Some of the music in this episode was provided by our friends at Okakumi from Hell Audio. Okakumi have a new 4-song EP that I just bought yesterday. It's on Bandcamp, it's called Sea Landsky. We are a project of 91.7KALW San Francisco and produced on Radio Row.
本周的“99%隐形”节目由埃米特·菲茨杰拉德制作，参与人员包括谢里·法瑟夫、凯蒂·明格、库尔特·科尔斯特ッド、萨姆·格林斯潘、艾弗里·特拉布尔曼以及我——罗曼·马尔斯。本集的部分音乐由我们在地狱音频的朋友奥卡库米提供。奥卡库米有一张我昨天刚买的新4首歌曲EP。它在Bandcamp上，名叫《海陆空》。我们是旧金山91.7KALW电台的一个项目，在广播街区制作。
In beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. You can find this show and like the show on Facebook. Follow all the people who work on this show on Twitter and Instagram with the best way to explore the 99% invisible activity that shapes the design of our world. stories on 99pi.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
地点位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽市中心。你可以在Facebook上找到并点赞本节目。在Twitter和Instagram上关注所有为本节目工作的人，这是探索塑造我们世界设计的99%隐形活动的最佳方式。故事尽在99pi.org。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。